and then it's just a way over your head
finding it as for your fun is like it's
a new favorite show it's so good it kind
of felt like The OC Meets The Goonies
yeah how would you guys explain it but
that one Goonies we're gonna keep that
one throwing some bloodline of those are
well Betsy we do teenage for you thank
you okay each receive either way it's
amazing and our mission this summer is
to have a good time all the time kind of
ready for that level of superstardom
that comes with being part of a Netflix
hit yeah it's the same thing yeah I
think we're really really I'm not gonna
say stratosphere okay I think we're in
this beautiful situation to where we
feel like we just got to create
something with a group of friends and
family because our showrunners our
directors our camera operators are all
like childhood friends and they grew up
together so yeah
we kind of really never got that
ideology of feeling like we're in this
giant world of the together the entire
globe be on our show until I know I
would really honestly say like right
lot of cool stunts dangerous moments
right yeah pretty much
probably pretty much my sister was my
stunt double did you guys have to train
for anything yeah yeah we did actually
put me in ukulele lessons and I make it
was more to like get into my character
so you didn't play the ukulele really
did you it's okay okay we needed all the
lessons yeah raining are you we had we
had a break we went to Wilmington worked
out this is really fun
yeah we hit all all of the surfing on us
I can I will say the best part of the
training is true my show
they gave him like a round weight to the
bottom hold your breath win like two
feet under and be like 245-pound of
plates to like actually get them to do
anything in the water putting a siege it
is john be fugitive by Jason I'm on a
treasure hunt
what do you guys think the ships are
gonna be because I think well I want a
key are you people are gonna ship these
two right just three any people are
gonna think you can you intercept us
yeah are gonna fit that I do I think
people are gonna ship you guys but I
think people want some romance for you
so what's yeah yeah
I'm crazy
yes oh yeah with a dog the entire were
you guys shocked
the more that you went into the season
about how things kind of unravel get
everything I want yeah we we had the
first four episodes at the start of
production and then as it progressively
came out we would have like these little
like fire settings where we'd sit and
was [ __ ] and we would all read
together
texting lies our cars yeah especially at
9:00 and 10:00 because it's super duper
yeah I didn't go off like yeah it's like
I think it's like why it's like it's
like eight eight three eight nine and
ten are all one day you're like say it's
like it can't get any worse oh I guess
it can yeah stakes get anybody will is
there a message that you guys have to
viewers for right after they watch the
final episode like they're gonna have
questions I'm sure you nor will watch it
again
watch it again series
be like yeah we should be like don't let
us know yeah I think the biggest thing
is is there if we I think we have
mastered the cliffhanger unless you're
sure finding it as for your fun ends
that's where all your problems begin
[Music]